let's go to your voicemails two one nine
two david p is our voicemail number
here's a voicemail that came in that i
found interesting to say the least
yes david pakman I believe that you and
Don Lemon should be fired both are
racist both are pinheads you only want
to focus on domestic terrorism that is
caused by white males you ignore the
crimes of all races you ignore like the
Florida City there was a serial killer
just shooting random people in Florida
about a year ago there's numerous many
vicious crimes they can be put under is
domestic terrorism and you and Don women
are totally idiots for just focusing and
a few mass shootings in recent days
because of the midterm elections you you
two are complete morons a complete
idiots and both of you should be
dismissed from your jobs as well this is
fake news analyst right so I have
nothing to do with CNN first of all and
I don't know what Don Lemon has to do
with me and of course anecdotally
pointing out that once a guy shot people
in Florida doesn't change the fact that
the overwhelming majority of domestic
terrorism is committed by the right as
far as firing me who's gonna fire me I'm
in charge here Troy and I know that that
bothers you but I am in charge here so
there's nobody who can fire me other
than every single member of the audience
saying we're not gonna listen anymore or
watch anymore which would be a de facto
firing but I don't know who you're
hoping is going to fire me we have a
great bonus show for you today we'll
talk about how the Republican house fund
is not helping Steve King because of his
association with white supremacists this
is good we'll talk about Native
Americans fighting back against a
northern North Dakota voter ID law and
we will talk about the GoFundMe
campaigns for Christine Blasi Ford
there's actually an interesting story
related to those go phone
me campaigns and we're gonna deal with
that on today's bonus show sign up for
membership at WWE at medCom you can also
get access to the bonus show by making a
5 dollar or greater a month pledge
should say a 5 dollar a month or greater
pledge on patreon at patreon.com slash
david pakman show two ways to get the
bonus show you will love the bonus show
either way and I look forward to
speaking to you then